the Joe Rogan experience well when your
first actual film film was well 2004 mm
mm yeah because the way it went down was
this is a funny story too I made my
first movie house 1000 corpses at
Universal Studios and it was 2000 it
could have been even the tail-end in
1999 I'm not sure they don't resent
knows mm I had a wrap gift somebody gave
me and they put a date I was like oh she
knows mm so I made the movie with
Universal Studios and once they screened
it we had our test screening which I
thought when I thought went great and
well I know that the head of Universal
at the time came up and was like we have
to talk tomorrow and that was not a good
tone that wasn't it you're so great we
want to give you a 5 picture deal tone
of voice so the next day they dumped the
movie and you know just basically booted
us out and then I pose the conversation
they were like we basically this is
unreleasable I don't remember word for
word but that was the conversation in a
nutshell but at the time too you figured
there was no horror coming out of
Universal they were making like The
Flintstones movie and that was not the
image they wanted this really vile sort
of backwoods hillbilly murder fest where
there's bad people win essentially I
mean horror films were sort of like not
even a commercial thing at that point in
a way so then which is funny now if you
go to Universal Studios Hollywood
Orlando there's a huge house of a
thousand Corpses thing event going on in
both theme parks that's a lair I was
there for the old grand opening like
that's funny like if I get rain it's
like I get fired from here and now you
know 20 years later it's a theme park
attraction in the exact place I got
fired for him Wow which is so weird what
was the conversation like before you
decided to do that film I mean how did
how did they let you do it I don't you
know I had again I think getting to make
a movie for Universal Studios was such
an amazing experience but I think I was
too naive to understand what was
happening it'd be like you did one set
of Komsomol yeah we got to put you on
tour George Carter like cool I guess
it's the way it happens
you know and it's after like wow I
didn't really appreciate just went down
did I not that I was took it for granted
but I had I had met with someone at the
theme park about doing a haunted maze
during their horror Halloween Horror
Nights based on my album and then sort
of by being in the offices was meeting
meeting people and having just meetings
about stuff or I just didn't want to
leave once I got in the studio I just
loved being there even though I had no
business being there and somehow I
remember being in the guy his name was
Kevin Mischer his office pitching him a
movie I didn't have a pitch for I have a
title but not nothing else and somehow
it progressed from there I was like
really I told them kind of a cool title
with a completely half-assed idea that
was making up as I was talking to
remember I was weird I don't even I I
can't remember it well because it after
the fact I'm like how did this happen I
don't remember this is like your story's
like the anti ambition story it's like
the anti preparation story exactly for
successful nonetheless yeah I guess the
the goal is just be vague with people
you don't care and I had that attitude
too I remember once the movie was
rolling I was like this is what I want
to cast and this is exactly what I want
to do and if you guys don't want to do
it that's cool let's just not work
together and they did it Wow like that's
a great picture my part right and I we
shot it on the universal back lot we're
like right there like doing the whole
thing and big production and it was
weird Wow when when it wrapped like
final day final scene and that's a wrap
were you like what the [ __ ] just
happened well the funny thing is like
after we wrapped the first time we had a
little test screening within the studio
like friends like oh we should probably
punch up the ending so they gave me like
they gave me more money to reshoot the
ending that I actually made my newest
movie with it was like money was nothing
like you know there's throwing money
around like it was like nothing else I
got my cousin saying we were building
these giant sets
it was after that that you know the
problem started but I don't I wish I
could remember these things better it's
weird that I don't but what attracted
you to this ultra violent psychopath
like outcasts murderous style of movie
that you do because you have like these
almost like mutant society psycho murder
people that I don't know but people
[ __ ] love it man
I've always dug like outsider mentality
like anything that involved like out I
think it started as a kid as a kid
because like a lot of people can relate
to this I didn't feel like I fit in like
I was like weird I didn't fit in I
didn't get like what were the cool shoes
to wear or the right freakin Izod sure I
didn't understand I wasn't trying to be
you know no one's trying to be weird and
like oh yeah I want to be weird and hide
away cuz I'm weird no it's like I don't
understand and I think when I would
watch new monster movies the monster was
always that mentality like King Kong's
like hey man I'm just trying to get
along why is everyone shooting at me in
Frankenstein's like hey I was just born
yesterday why you're trying to kill me
like and I think as a weird kid you
relate to the monster
so as life went on and you know the I
would always relate to the outsider then
I would always relate to movies like
taxi driver Bonnie and Clyde and yeah
and Travis Bickle you know he's the
[ __ ] man you know and I would always
be like anything anti-society Anthea
[ __ ] you [ __ ] everything that's normal
right like revenge yeah I was just into
it and I felt real similar when I was a
kid I was always in the monster movies I
was always into something that just just
tore all the normal people apart and
just ripped apart all the conceived
notions of what everybody thought was
gonna happen and then around the end
towards the end of high school when I
discovered punk rock II figure out
there's an entire form of music where
they're just like go [ __ ] yourself
yeah that's what we're here I was like
I'm in and so many other people as well
yeah and it's just like it just it flips
your whole idea of what life is and then
when I moved to New York I was like wow
this is the entire city of people don't
give
that's where they come yeah nobody gives
a [ __ ] about anything here it's it's
amazing how your movies resonate with
people like - like in a fanatical way
like the read the comments on just a
trailer for three from hell
you know just people are so [ __ ]
pumped yeah it's it's great and I mean
it's been a it's been a long journey
because like when my first movie came
out I think every review basically said
something along lines of worst movie
ever made I hate this movie and now
people do look that's your best movie
you know like you've been choosing the
river soon so it's just weird how same
with white zombie when our first gift we
still remember this our first Geffen
record came out I saw the first review
it was this magazine alternative press
who two years ago gave me this Lifetime
Achievement Award and I had to read the
review while accepting what the review
said this is the worst band ever come on
and it said this is the worst band ever
ignore this band yeah so there was
something and you know there must have
been something juror contacts a person
who wrote that now I didn't I back then
I was just like I mean like I felt like
maybe a few years later who was I I used
to be upset by reviews until I saw who
wrote them mmm yeah you know yeah that's
a lot of critics or critics cuz they
really wanted to be writers they just
don't have a lot to contribute and so
they just [ __ ] on things and it's just
like you as a when you're young and
you're new and you're reading you think
that the guys writing it frightening all
badass you'll think oh this dude must
look like Lemmy he must be this hard-ass
guy and I mean you see guys like that
guy wrote I'll [ __ ] him you [ __ ]
everyone else whoever writes I do you
think again I don't give a [ __ ]
[Applause]